[Music]
is it possible I could grow still at
this age yeah yeah for sure dude no I
mean a height oh maybe you take a [ __ ]
on a GH you might squeak out like half
an inch okay all right hey let's go
let's just balloon my organ have you
seen those people who like break their
[ __ ] legs Jesus but it works it's
gonna be me next year dude don't don't
speak too spicy it gives you like three
inches doesn't it I I hope so yeah I'm
locked in it's wild yeah I don't know
how much it's marketing behind some of
the before and afters or not but like
yeah some of these guys are really
rolling the dice to get another few
inches out hey man I'm going to China
next year so yeah no no I'm not
enough for Tor just to get longer yeah
right yeah what is your ideal height if
you could pick seven three or some [ __ ]
like that I just want to be six six foot
I actually don't want to be six foot I I
but why
I don't think okay yes you do no no no I
don't actually I don't
I want to be six too
yeah no if I want to be tall I want to
be [ __ ] tall I'll be like six seven
I'm not I'm not doing six one six two
that's that's dumb if I'm doing it I'm
going like a full foot I want to be
towering yeah otherwise there's no real
Point yo my man's showing off what the
hell yeah what the [ __ ] with the gray
sweats dude
rub your city bro yeah yeah he's
definitely repping his City dude
that's how much how many that's like hey
game like a full inch or what more than
that
dude that well look at his head goes up
to the third line after that main line
there and this is just taken from it
yeah I think it is it goes up to the
fourth yeah this is like an optical
illusion how [ __ ] what [ __ ] would it
be if you were actually had misleading
marketing on limb lengthening surgery
where you just took different angles to
convince people to smash their legs
apart that's kind of what I feel like
I'm looking at maybe
yeah those Polynesian sounds pretty good
bro is he on his knees in the before
that is [ __ ] up dude that's a full
like that's like a foot yeah and
obviously you'd be skeptical immediately
as like can this guy even walk properly
yeah I know yeah after they take the
picture he just Falls like sick thanks
I mean he's got shorts dude that's a
bold move yeah
bro the pants on in the first one shorts
in the second I just feel this has to be
deceptive marketing man maybe yeah
yeah I can't devise I can't buy in I'm
not Soldier I wonder what it costs that
would be interesting we looked it up in
a recent video
um not for research just for video Yeah
it jumped purely yeah yes just for video
yeah yeah that's all it wasn't
I think it was like 180 Grand or
something it was something were you
about to say it's not that bad no no I
was gonna say like it's it's not uh it's
not like a like a BBL or some [ __ ] where
it's like oh it's like it's not like a
justifiable amount where it's like oh
well for 20 grand you know like it's not
a reasonable number it's something
that's yeah 250 I guess or one sorry 120
for tibia
250 for combined that'd be so hard to
vet out what you actually need to
because like who are you going to ask
for like do I need the tibia one or do I
need this yeah there's like one guy who
knows the answer and the guy who's doing
the 200. you need them all yeah yeah you
need both yeah yeah you need to smash
your entire leg it just knocks your
[ __ ] like I need both I need both
yeah no I I know this number because the
last bit like one of the most recent
videos I did with these two dudes Jay
and Trey they're from Toronto they're
both like just tall as [ __ ] so they've
been making fun of me like [ __ ]
non-stop they're like
like are you thinking about it dude they
send me merch and I they're like what
size are you and I'm like bro
don't make you say it yeah I'm like
Don't make me say it just guessing and
then I was just saying like I was gonna
hire these people to break their legs
and give me their [ __ ] phones like
yeah when you wake up five eight
tomorrow you'll know that [ __ ] was me
dude my friend got me shoes that they're
like that they're called the like lazuri
Cloud lifts or something like that okay
and they're like high heels for dudes
but like they look like normal shoes
yeah but they have three inches of lift
on them so for one night I was six feet
tall and I went out
and had the best time did it feel like
your knees were getting messed up or
anything while you're walking I mean I
think that's one of the reasons why
reasons why so injured like have been
able to train for like four weeks now
because my back is so [ __ ] up I think
that's one of the reasons Jesus because
I was walking on my toes the whole night
but I mean people were treating me with
respect let's just say that did you
notice the difference or did you just
feel more confident I definitely felt
different like I was like looking my
friends in the eye that were normally
you know way taller than me oh bro like
that's the craziest one yeah yeah it is
the perspective yeah it's [ __ ] weird
like you've never looked up at a front
door
I don't know maybe
I feel like you're always probably
looking down at a front door how tall
are you like six one six one yeah okay
okay pretty good that's a yeah maybe
you're like about as tall as the door
not that tall get the [ __ ] out of here
I'm just saying I'm six I'm six feet
with my Missouri Cloud left on so that's
true that's not that big of a look up
you know
the high thing is
it's tough dude so because sometimes I
think if I if we were taller or
something I don't think we could be who
we are yeah it's like people who get mad
at comedians or big names who lose
weight when they were known for being
fat or something yeah people got mad at
Adele when she got in shape yeah yeah
yeah and certain comedians they lose
they're kind of like the gimmick a
little bit or something when they get in
shoes [ __ ] up yeah yeah but you can't
be happy for them if you're a fan you're
like you don't look the same anymore so
we don't like you yeah that is a weird
thing yeah I you know
I don't have that problem nice dude
there's only reason I set up the whole
trying bit Yeah well so I could have it
I feel like if I got yoked people be
like well noelle's eating that we're so
happy for him I feel like I'd actually
get a positive response you think maybe
I feel like if you showed up with 20
pounds more muscle people would be like
you sell out oh interesting I should try
to do it then you should definitely try
to do it huge
you gotta do I mean I think a dream the
dream
for a guy
is to pull what um what's his name Cal
is that his name
yes
well just like kind of you know not for
a while he got heat for that yeah he
didn't really get heat for it he was
used to be like uh I don't know
anti-masculinity guy or something and
then all of a sudden he shows up with
like a jawline from the gods and cranked
out of his [ __ ] tree yeah okay I love
that phrase cranked out of his tree yeah
yeah that's a great phrase
I mean that I mean to me that's like
just to fall off the face of the Earth
for a little while and then come back
and be like look what I've been doing
yeah like for a dude I feel like that'd
be the greatest feeling ever yeah look
at a [ __ ] jacked I am right now yeah
if I start shooting maybe I could do
that
shooting like ah I don't know I I will
say if I have commitment my body
actually does like it will accept like
the calories and we'll do something with
it like yeah I'm sure you haven't even
optimized you said earlier you're like
well I've kind of like learned what my
potential is it's like I don't think
you've actually tried bro oh hell yeah
dude there's a little challenge right
the fact that you haven't even been able
to bulk with ice cream like you have not
tried let's be honest dude I love this
coach keep going yeah keep going nah I
so
um
I'm finally on like a program that I
actually am committing to so I'm as of
like a couple weeks ago I am hitting
like four or five days a week but it's
like the program itself is actually
challenging it's not like a program
where I'm just sitting there
kind of doing the Motions right but I'm
not really like sweating it out or like
trying to push my body so I'm curious to
see where I can take it and it's a
program I can maintain while traveling
so I am Keen to see what I can do in a
year and you have zero excuse no no yeah
you have a [ __ ] beautiful gym I do in
your house you have zero excuse I wish
you could come see it man it is [ __ ] but
yeah I feel like that's a fitness
person's dream yeah no it's awesome
um so yeah maybe uh okay so here's what
we have to do we have to do another
episode
in
a I don't know eight months six months a
year what do you think a year from now
I'll show up and you better be huge okay
you have to coach the you have to coach
us though
okay yeah yeah for free
[Laughter]